bon il y a de la joie de l'énergie et de
l'enthousiasme et moi ça me plaît c'est
notre dernier conseil national avant la
primaire savourons ce moment
oui oui savourons ce moment nous aimons
ces instants où toute notre famille se
réunit où venu de tous les coins de
France nous sommes rassemblés par la
même passion de la politique c'est une
belle passion et merci surtout à vous
d'être venu
de nous soutenir depuis maintenant des
mois de nous avoir aidé à redonner sa
dynamique à notre parti et aujourd'hui
au moment où les grandes batailles vont
s'enclencher vous pouvez avoir la fierté
pour la première fois depuis des années
notre parti a regagné des adhérents la
dynamique est à nouveau de notre côté et
croyez-moi c'est de très bon augure pour
alorscas nous
teerons parce que nous savons ce que
nous te
devons tu as sauvé notre famille de la
catastrophe tu lui as redonné un
souffle tu lui as redonné ton
énergie cet après-midi nous avons enfin
un programme des idées que nous
défendons nos valeurs et je peux
témoigner que tu n'as pas ménager à
peine remarquez pour bien le connaître
l'inverse aurait été surprenant
tout le monde le sait Nicolas a
considérablement
changé pas trop quand même et croyez-moi
sur le plan de l'énergie il est toujours
aussi épuisant pour ceux qui travaillent
avec
[Applaudissements]
lui alors je ne sais pas ce que tu feras
à la rentrée Nicolas on est quelquesuns
à avoir quelques idées pour toi mais au
nom de toute la famille merci pour le
chemin
accompli
merci à
Éric merci à François merci à Luc merci
à Christian merci pour leur travail
inlassable et leur esprit d'équipe merci
à Alain merci à François merci à Michel
merci à Jean-François à Nathalie à Hervé
qui par leur présence ont montré qu'ils
n'oubliaent pas l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est l'unité merci à
vous
merci anadine qui je sais ce matin a été
très applaudi et elle le mérite merci à
toi
Nadine la compétition la compétition mes
amis c'est normal mais la division c'est
insupportable et après la primaire
viendra le rassemblement n'oublions
jamais que ce qui nous rassemble est
infiniment plus important que ce qui
nous divise et qu'il y a un engagement
absolu après la primaire c'est tous unis
derrière le vainqueur une seule ligne
une seule volonté François Hollande
c'est
dehors monsieur 12
% 12 % moi j'en reviens pas qu' a encore
12 % des Français qui lui fassent
confiance en tout cas ici il y en a
aucun qui se
trompe mais la France dans quel état
ont-ils mis la France le symbole de leur
quinquena pour moi restera cette
commémoration de Verdin avec un
président de la République de la France
qui jouait les portes parapluies pour
Angela Merkel et des jeunes qui
couraient sur les tombes de nos soldats
des soldats morts pour la patrie c'est
indigne mais c'est surtout l'exemple
pitoyable de ce qu' a été leur quinquen
ils ont piétiné nos valeurs ils ont
piétiné notre histoire la France ce
n'est pas cela la France pour nous c'est
autre chose et nous voulons remettre la
France la tête à l'endroit une France
fière de ses valeurs et de son histoire
alors la tâche ne tia pas facile il y
faudra de l'énergie il y faudra du
courage ce n'est pas la CGT qui dirigera
notre pays nous ne céderons pas face aux
menaces de grève il n'y aura pas de
petits accords d'ouverture à gauche en
direction d'Emmanuel Macron ou de je ne
sais pas qui qui viendrait à la soupe
après les
campagnes nous ne voulons pas de
demi-réforme il n'y aura pas de filet
d'eau tiède
tout simplement parce que nous savons
trop que nous avons trop laissé le FN
récupérer les mots de nation de
frontières de protection et même de
France mais le FN en réalité c'est
l'extrême gauche nous devons dénoncer
leurs mensonge nous ne pouvons plus les
laisser se nourrir de nos faiblesses et
si nous voulons redresser le pays alors
il faudra assumer nos convictions la
droite ce n'est pas la gauche et nous ne
voulons pas passer notre temps à nous
excuser des valeurs de la droite nous en
sommes fiers et nous les assumerons au
grand
jour la première valeur
éic la plus importante c'est le travail
pour les socialistes on vit pour le
loisir pour nous le travail donne du
sens à la vie les socialistes monsieur
le Premier ministre ont cassé les heures
supplémentaires ils ont supprimé les
jours de carence ils ont fait des
cadeaux à toutes leur clientèle
électorale et pire que ça ils ont mis en
place un RSA pour les jeunes des jeunes
qui qui quitte les bans de l'université
et auquel on verse une prestation
sociale pour les supplier d'accepter de
revenir étudier mais dans quel pays
est-on tombé maintenant il est temps que
les socialistes arrêtent ce travail de
déconstruction alors oui nous croyons au
travail et pas laassistana alors il faut
assumer de dire que le travail doit
payer plus qu'il faut bien évidemment
qu'en cumulant toutes les prestations
sociales on ne puisse jamais aller
au-delà de 75 % du SMIC parce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une différence claire entre
celui qui qui reste chez lui et celui
qui veut
travailler alors il faut assumer de dire
qu'en contrepartie du RSA on doit exiger
systématiquement des heures de travail
d'intérêt général parce que quand on a
des droits on a aussi des devoirs en
France et ne laissons pas les
socialistes implanter cette idée stupide
qui détruit notre pays le travail ça
n'est pas une punition il n'y a pas une
gauche qui est pour la solidarité et une
droite qui est contre il y a une droite
qui croit au travail et une gauche qui
n'y croit plus et c'est toute la
différence entre eux et
nous et c'est aussi parce que nous
croyons au travail et je veux en
remercier les militants de l'uni qui
nous ont accompagné que dans notre
région nous avons rétabli les bourses au
mérit pour nos bacheliers et nos
étudiants parce que chez nous on croit
au travail à l'effort et à
l'excellence assumons aussi de dire
qu'il faudra donner la priorité à nos
entreprises les travailleurs détachés
ont fait beaucoup de mal à l'Europe en
novern Ronald nous avons mis en place un
système de préférence locale pour que
dans nos marchés publics on puisse
donner la priorité à nos entreprises et
pour nous cette notion de préférence
n'est pas un gros mot l'Europe a le
droit de défendre ses intérêts
économiques pourquoi serions-nous la
seule zone géopolitique au monde à ne
pas donner d'abord la priorité à nos
propres tissu industriels et à laisser
les concurrents rentrer dans le marché
européen
sans la moindre protection c'est une
absurdité les États-Unis ne le font pas
la Chine ne le fait pas nous ne voulons
plus que l'Europe s'enferme dans cet
impasse car oui
Nicolas comme tu l'as dit il faut
changer l'Europe tu l'avais dit avant le
brexit et notre conviction n'est que
plus affirmée cette Europe qui s'est
plongé dans un élargissement sans fin
nous amené dans une impasse nous ne
sommes pas contre l'Europe mais nous
sommes contre contre ce que l'Europe est
devenu et nous avons la conviction
qu'avec autant de pays ça ne peut pas
marcher l'élargissement sans fin doit
s'arrêter nous devons exiger de François
Hollande qu'il sortte des ambigués les
négociations avec la Turquie doivent
immédiatement cesser on est au côté du
peuple turc face au terrorisme mais la
Turquie n'entrera jamais dans l'Union
[Applaudissements]
européenne parce que la frontière mes
amis ça n'est pas un gros
motendre ses frontières ça n'est pas un
gros mot et la France revendique la
possibilité de contrôler qui rentre chez
elle pour y faire quoi elle revendique
la liberté de dire qu'on ne vient en
France que pour y travailler et pas pour
bénéficier d'un système de solidarité
nationale qu'on offre beaucoup trop
généreusement à des étrangers qui n'ont
même jamais cotisé dans notre
pays n'oubliez pas cette belle phrase de
standal ils prennent ulement de leur âme
pour de la civilisation et de la
générosité c'est encore vrai pour tous
ces politiques qui refusent d'agir ils
prennent leur faiblesse et leur molesse
pour de l'humanisme et ils appellent ça
le respect des droits de l'homme ils ont
oublié que la faiblesse de nos états
fait la fortune des passeurs et la mort
des plus pauvres ils ont oublié que le
premier devoir d'un état c'est de faire
respecter l'autorité et que c'est la
première condition de l'humanisme en
France
oui
l'autorité l'autorité à tous les niveaux
Nicolas comme tu l'incarnais depuis le
chef d'État jusqu'aux parents et aux
instituteur jamais l'autorité de l'État
n'a été aussi bafouée imaginez sous
pierre mandz France déjà le général de
Gaulle trouvait que l'autorité de l'État
allait en sa'affaissant je n'ose penser
ce qu'il penserait en ayant vu un
président de la République avec son
petit casque de scooter je préfère ne
même pas entendre la voix du
général pourrouver le sens de l'autorité
Roger Guillaume il faut rompre
radicalement avec l'idéologie qui nous a
mené jusque- là avec cette idéologie
antiprison avec cette idéologie
antipolice avec cette idéologie
antisanction qui n'a pour seul objectif
que de déconstruire tout les cadres il
faut que chacun retrouve son rôle il
faut un président qui décide il faut une
police qui protège et il faut surtout
une justice qui sanctionne et qui
condamne
redonne à la France Rachida sa vraie
valeur c'est le refus absolu du
communautarisme toi qui le porte avec
autant de détermination et de l'islam
politique ne nous faisons aucune
illusion il y a les terroristes mais il
y a aussi ceux qui mènent un combat
culturel pour étendre le port du voile
la séparation des hommes et des femmes
et tout simplement imposer leurs règles
à la France j'entends d'ici les bonnes
consciences de gauche crier amalgame
amalgame mais personne dans cette salle
ne fait d'amalgame personne ne fait
d'amalgame entre les islamistes qui
assassinent et nos concitoyens musulmans
par contre tout le monde ici exige de
l'islam français qu'il soit capable
aussi de prendre parti pour la France et
qu'il récuse sans la moindre ambiguïé
l'islamisme radical parce que la France
c'est l'assimilation c'est
l'assimilation et qu'il n'y a pas de
voix pour le communautarisme dans notre
pays on a trop
accepté que chacun oppose son droit la
différence et on a oublié de défendre ce
que nous avons en commun la gauche a
démissionné et elle a fait le choix
électoraliste du communautarisme c'est
l'honneur de notre famille politique de
ne pas baisser les bras et de porter ce
message simple en France c'est
l'assimilation et il y a ici des gens
qui sont des exemples de ces familles
venus de l'immigration qui sont venus en
France en disant à leurs enfants la
France est un grand pays tu dois le
chérir mon fils ma fille et tu qui doit
devenir plus français que les Français
c'est cela la voix singulière de la
France la France est l'assimilation la
France ça n'est pas le
communautarisme et c'est pour cette
raison qu' lon Philippe Christophe et je
suis fier de votre soutien nous avons
refusé de financer un institut musulman
qui voulait être construit à Lyon payé
pour moitié par des fonds venant de pays
étrangers quand est-ce que nous allons
cesser d'accepter que l'Algérie ou des
pays du golf VI ici tisser leur réseau à
l'ombre de nos mosquées quand est-ce que
nous allons ouvrir les yeux c'est la
France et il n'ont rien à faire
ici je crois qu'au
fond et je voudrais finir par là
redonner à la France sa vraie valeur
cela passera par la redécouverte de
notre héritage commun je crois que notre
société toute entière a perdu le sens de
la transmission que voulons nous
transmettre à nos enfants une société ne
peut pas subsister sans cette capacité à
transmettre ses valeurs et son histoire
de génération en génération nous ne
voulons pas que notre pays change de
nature c'est au fond le message qui
était celui de la vice écouter ces
paroles magnifiques qui n'ont jamais été
autant d'actualité tu dois aimer la
France parce que la nature l'a faite
belle et parce que l'histoire l'a faite
grande est-ce démodé non l'amour de la
France ce n'est pas démodé notre pays
retrouvera le sens de l'avenir en
redécouvrant ses racines et ses
fondations et en retrouvant la fierté de
son histoire dans une époque de doute il
ne suffit pas de transmettre seulement
les valeurs de la République il faut
aussi il faut surtout transmettre
l'amour de la France alors n'ayons pas
peur n'ayons pas peur parce qu'au moment
où tout semble perdu après ces 5 années
pitoyables de nouvelles forces se lèvent
les Français aspirent plus que jamais à
retrouver des repères les drapeaux
français sont à nouveau aux fenêtres les
Marseillaises sont à nouveau tené
fièrement la France s'est réveillée et
elle a besoin de nous ce n'est pas une
occasion pour reconquérir le pouvoir
c'est une responsabilité pour redresser
le pays un pays dans lequel nous voulons
que celui qui travaille gagne plus que
celle qui reste chez lui un pays dans
lequel l'étudiant qui se donne du mal
doit être récompensé un pays dans lequel
on arrête d'excuser les délinquants un
pays dans lequel c'est à l'étranger de
s'adapter à la République et non à la
République de s'adapter à l'étranger ces
valeurs ce sont celles dont la France a
besoin ces valeurs ce sont les nôtres
alors militants des républicains c'est à
vous que nous en appelons levons-nous
levons-nous et engageons-nous
levons-nous et défendons nos valeurs
levons-nous pour que la France
redevienne la France que nous
aimons